- I wish more than anything that I could go back
and redo my prom.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] You are going to Buzzfeed Queer Prom.
- Oh my God, this rainbow.
(upbeat music)
- [All] Queer prom!
- [Woman Off Screen] This prom feels a ton gayer
than all of my other proms.
- [Man Off Screen] This is my first time going to prom.
I feel as though it's like, prom is for everybody.
- I don't think I've ever felt this masculine
in my entire life.
- [Woman Off Screen 2] I want them to look at me and say
she's a homosexual.
- [Man Off Screen 2] I feel like I'm ready to have
a night I'll never forget.
- [Woman Off Screen 3] It's not like, oh I'm just going
to prom to go to prom, it's going to prom to go to prom.
- I think the one thing that I'm gonna take away
from Queer Prom this year was that, I'm normal.
- I can honestly say for like, the first time in my life,
like, I actually feel beautiful.
- To still be yourself and shine as bright
as all of the colors in our rainbow.
- [Woman Off Screen 4] Everybody that's queer,
like, goes through the same kind of stuff
and that we have each other, no matter where we come from.
- [Woman Off Screen 5] Don't be afraid
to put yourself out there.
- [Man Off Screen 3] Having gone through this experience
has definitely boosted my confidence and made me
feel more like me.
♪ Dance with me ♪
♪ Let's do this thing tonight alright ♪
♪ Come with me ♪
♪ Step into the light ♪
♪ Dance with me ♪
♪ Let's do this thing tonight alright ♪
(sign swings)